peut-être rappeler enfin je n'ai pas
fait mais nous étions le conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel nous sommes
aujourd'hui l'autorité de régulation la
communication audiovisuelle et numérique
donc nous sommes compétents sur les
contenus audiovisuels et numériques
nous ne sommes pas compétents sur la
chaîne de fabrication de ces contenus
nous ne sommes pas compétents sur
les entreprises sur ce qui se passe au
sein de ces entreprises sur les
recrutements sur la manière dont sont
traités les personnes au sein des
entreprises donc nous ne sommes pas
compétents c'est donc les questions qui
les préconisations qui sont les vôtres
et je les comprends et je pourrais même
vous dire que je les partage mais nous
ne sommes pas compétents c'est à dire
que ce sont il faut s'adresser aux
tribunaux
l'art comme n'est pas compétente sur des
questions l'art comme son travail et sa
mission confiée par le législateur c'est
de mettre en conformité des sites
pornographiques c'est-à-dire de
s'assurer que ces sites pornographiques
ne sont pas accessibles aux mineurs
donc notre problématique à l'art comme
celle-là c'est de s'assurer que les
sites pornographiques ne soit pas
accessible aux mineurs c'est notre seule
mission qui soit la nôtre est
effectivement ce que vous décrivez
nous ne sommes malheureusement nous ne
sommes pas compétents je sais pas s'il
faut le regretter je pense que il ya
d'autres autorités qui le sont et il
faut je pense justement je peux être
dans le cadre de cette mission mais sans
doute prévu échanger avec elle mais
notre mission est née celle ci
donc c'est pour ça que ya peut-être un
malentendu
sur ce que nous sommes et notre
compétence et
donc jusqu'ici comme je le disais
jusqu'à la loi du 30 juillet 2020 notre
compétence elle s'exerçait sur les
médias classiques donc la télévision
la radio et services de médias le
rattrapage
cette loi de 2020 elle souhaité nous
donner compétence est donné compétence
au président de l'art comme pour faire
en sorte effectivement que ces sites ne
soit pas accessoire nos graphiques ne
soit pas accessible
aux mineurs donc il s'agit même pas ni
d'interdire la pornographie il s'agit de
faire en sorte de protéger les mineurs
et de faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas
accès pour pouvoir ensuite s'épanouir
voilà pleinement et préserver leurs
droits à l'innocence
[Musique]